hi everyone it's Jerry let's have a look
at a game that was played at the 2019
Tata steel Masters on the white end
vishyanand and he's playing against
chakriar mama diarov
okay we have a caracon defense Advanced
variation
immediate pressure on the base point
it's given up
and now E6 normally in the caracon
defense this light Square Bishop the bad
Bishop will try to get outside of the
pawn chain
but not with this variation
black is with E6 placing an emphasis on
simply recapturing the pun
okay let's get some more development in
white preps B4
Knight E7 and Bishop D3 this is an
optimal diagonal for the bishop there's
really no good reason to put it on E2
it's not like we're fearing in some
cases a an annoying pin
you also wouldn't want to be on E2
because you get in in the way of a white
Rook once it's on E1
white needs to take into account
the E5 Pawn because of White's decision
on move 4 to take away from the center
he doesn't have a convenient Defender
over E5
what does this mean
the white pieces will have that
responsibility
the black pieces naturally can naturally
exert pressure on E5 the queen Knight
developing to C6 Queen C7 the king
Knight could get in on the mix and let's
not forget about the F Pawn who can also
be a contributor
okay we continue with Knight G6 both
sides Castle White connects Knights
expands on the queen side
and now where do we go from here
well when I skimmed to through this game
I thought to myself you follow
B4
with Bishop to B2 white does after all
in this position have to do something
about E5
currently has two attackers one Defender
so
shouldn't we go ahead and develop a new
piece
this is not how white plays it
if the bishop is posted on B2 Knight f4s
can be played and it's a little bit
irritating
to deal with this night
um is white okay with the light Square
Bishop for Night Exchange well he is but
he wants to do it in a different way
what am I talking about well in this
position he simply swipes the Knight
there's going to be some structural
change now on Black's King's side
how to recapture
black is a rule breaker
he takes with the F Pawn
he's not going towards the center
keeping a pawn island of five
this recapture is fully Justified the
computer prefers this recapture over
towards the center
what is the big positive here for black
the f file
The Rook is immediately activated
you could also say that the quality of
the dark Square Bishop has been improved
there's a big intersection Square here
on F2 that white needs to take into
account and he does in this game
is now the time for white to finally
develop the bishop to B2
no
when is
it a good time for white to put the
bishop on B2 well if black makes a
different decision
on this recapture
if black takes towards the center this
is where the computer likes Bishop to B2
you'll note within this structure F2 is
not as sensitive
well within this structure
it is so White's idea is to try and
tame the dark Square Bishop try and
exchange the dark Square Bishops and
there are two reasons that support this
way of play
one the pressure on F2 as already
mentioned in two black has the bishop
pair and usually it's a good strategy to
try and eliminate one of those Bishops
so white begins with Knight B3 his idea
rookie one Bishop E3
okay
Bishop D7 didn't have any other squares
rookie one
A5 met with B5
A4 we don't want this bishop getting
activated the pawns are around to tame
it
from here Rook to C8 so this is actually
a pretty big moment in the game I would
say
I mean black knows that this is an idea
by white so why is black maybe not
trying to prevent this move
in other words why isn't black maybe
playing Knight F5 here
it's because white would have this
excellent move
C4
what is happening with C4 well it's
carving out a square for a night
after d takes C this Knight can go here
next here and this is a very weak Square
the computer is really drawn to this
variation here it likes White's position
a real lot
well with Black's move Rook C8 in this
position he's taking the C4 move into
account C4 is not possible in this
position
okay
Bishop E3
dark Square Bishop exchange Knight F5
Rook D3
G5 met with H3 flight square or also
stabilizing our Knight we don't want him
scared away so easily
and in this position black continues
with B6 seems like a perfectly
reasonable way to play
you don't want this queen
forever there watching over the A5 Pawn
this seems like the more convenient
defender of A5 so she can go elsewhere
now
the computer however does not like B6
here
has a preference for a caveman approach
it wants to go with H5 next looking at
G4 to Rattle the night position maybe
even open up a square
for the queen on G5 or H4
black does not play in this way he goes
with B6 and now
it is all the sudden
seems like out of nowhere but this is
the case white is now
winning
Can you spot the winning move here for
white
feel free to pause the video
okay may seem surprising and I imagine
it surprised
when this game was played
the winning move is
C4
the position is getting blasted open now
and white is the better prepared
side for the opening up of this position
it seems crazy playing C4 I mean wasn't
the idea with Rook C8 to stop this very
Advanced White is still able to play in
this way
why well if black first of all takes
with the pawn that's
met with Rook takes Bishop we can't do
that
we could take with the Rook this is how
black plays it but now there is this
follow-up
Rook takes D5
see the idea
if black recaptures The Rook White's
recapturing with check and then he gets
the Rook back he's up a pawn in this
position this is completely winning this
isn't just any pawn by the way it's a
passer
completely winning position here for
white
now
black in this position plays Rook to F7
The Rook falls back let me go back to
this sequence
the pawn advance to C4 the pop quiz I
threw your way
if you didn't spot this move and I
imagine many didn't it's a very sharp
looking move you have to see C4 you have
to see the follow-up Rook takes D5 how
could you maybe be in a better position
to
find this star move
I think if we're maybe a bit more
attentive to the rule that was breaking
a little further back this capture F
takes G6 maybe we could be
a bit closer to finding the C4 move what
am I talking about well
when I
initially made that move F takes on G6 I
only pointed out a positive
I started talking about The Rook being
activated the f file being opened I
pointed out the bishop
it became a better piece because of the
intersection on F2 but what I didn't
point out on purpose
were potential drawbacks
I think if you're attentive to the
potential drawbacks by capturing away
from the center you might be a little
bit closer to finding a move like C4
what is a potential drawback or two or
three by capturing in this way well
what are some things we could know E6 as
a whole
we can say that the seventh rank has
become a little bit more weakened with
their no longer being a Pawn on F7 if
there's ever a white major piece on the
seventh rank This Heart of the king side
structure has direct pressure on it and
lastly
the point that's really showing up in
this game is the weakened diagonal
no Pawn on F7 the king is now more
vulnerable to some variations where
there's a check on the diagonal there's
now only two Pawns
on this diagonal instead of three only
two barriers to remove in order for a
forceful continuation such as Queen
takes D5 check
okay
in short being a little bit more
attentive to some deficiency on this
diagonal may lead you towards C4 In This
Very position
okay we continue with Rook takes C4
Rook takes D5
have to do something about the bishop he
defends it
Rook D3
G4 is tried again this is at this point
just to completely winning position now
for white with C4 ever since C4 has been
played
the Knight simply returns with Tempo and
there's also now a second attacker on G4
Brook B4 is played Pawn takes
white is now up a pawn
Knight gets back into the mix there's
now also this threat The Rook is not
defending in this current position
Knight takes up this nice Central post
night is improved you're cutting off
white is cutting off the pressure on G4
here
Rook F4
Knight C2
The Rook is hit and there is yet again
this idea to take advantage of
this diagonal
Rook takes Knight follows Pawn takes
Rook one more move in this game that's
how quickly this game collapsed after C4
Queen takes D5 check this goes no
further
black simply resigns
he's soon going to lose the bishop
there's nothing he can do about that
if the game continued
let's say the King goes to the corner
white can double up and you can't defend
the bishop
Rook F7 is no good
if you don't try to get out of the pin
in this position there could be E6
could win the two pieces you could play
this two pieces for The Rook position
from there
completely winning for white if we have
just one sample line let's say queen C8
we get some exchange like this let's say
there's a flight square look at the
perfect coordination so what if this
Pawn Falls
this guy is running
something like this
you could glue that pawn right in and
there's even ideas to check from here
with the fork also just cutting off The
Rook from stopping the pawn
plenty of ways to play it from here to
be sure but Mahmoud yarov knew there's
no hope in this very position in simply
threw in the towel
anyhow Feel Free as usual to leave any
feedback to this video in the comments
section below I hope you enjoyed it and
maybe took a thing or two away that's
all for now take care bye
foreign